all right welcome everybody
it is saturday and we are standing by
for a briefing scheduled for the top of
the hour 11 a.m
uh eastern here in the east as as you
could probably tell
from uh donald trump's white house dr
sean
conley now i will talk in a moment about
whether
this is an individual that should be
seen as a medical professional versus
as a mouthpiece of propaganda or some
combination of the two
but we we will get to that in a moment
um i do want to get everybody caught up
on what's going on as you can see
uh a a number of trump supporters have
started to
i i hate to even ascribe this word to it
but hold a vigil
at walter reed medical center for donald
trump um
it is a a maskless trump flag waving
um event i guess is what we are going to
call it
and i have some clips from some
individuals who were interviewed last
night who were holding trump flags and
uh you know doing doing those sorts of
things um
the to catch everybody up well maybe
i'll wait a little bit to catch people
up from
from the get-go um let's just start with
with what has been donald trump's
twitter activity over the last
short period of time um so
very very early yesterday morning so
really like a day and a half ago
donald trump tweeted tonight flotus and
i tested positive for covid19 we will
begin our quarantine and recovery
process immediately
we will get through this together and
then we heard nothing from donald trump
from 16 hours
for 16 hours and then 16 hours
ago um we
saw this video from donald trump this
was a video with the same clothes he
wore as he
walked out to the helicopter to be
brought over to
walter reed medical center some people
noticing that his hair
seemed to be parted on the opposite side
of what we've seen
forever with donald trump i'm not really
sure he does look different but
you know he's sick and this was the
message from donald trump yesterday via
video this was released
literally as he touched down at walter
reed medical center
i want to thank everybody for the
tremendous support
i'm going to walter reed hospital i
think i'm doing very well
but we're going to make sure that things
work out the first lady is doing very
well
so thank you very much i appreciate it i
will never forget it thank you
and then this thing of i think was
something that came up again
last night late last night uh at about
11 30 p.m eastern time donald trump
using this phrase i think again go this
is from the hospital now
uh going well i think
thank you to all love and again this
thing about
you think has become a big phrase
whose meaning we really just don't know
at this point in time
so that is the bulk of donald trump's
twitter activity for the very
very uh recent couple of days here we
are standing by at walter reed for dr
sean connolly dr sean connelly is going
to update us about donald trump's
condition in about 20 minutes
now is dr sean connelly merely a doctor
or is dr sean conley
a trump administration official who is
going to lie to us it's a bit of both
and i i you know there's been a big
battle that has started raging
among uh the the twitter sphere
about can we is trump really sick
is this some kind of plan oh you
leftists are crazy with the conspiracy
so let let's like
you know you don't need a grand unifying
theory for everything but there sort of
is one here
which doesn't require saying well does
he even have coronavirus or not
here's my take on this this is an
administration that has lied about
everything including trump's health
okay when dr harold bornstein wrote this
letter that we found out he wrote like
in a limb
he went into trump's limo and wrote it
for him saying donald trump would be the
healthiest president ever to be
president that's hyperbole
that a doctor can't say if a doctor
hasn't examined every president in
history
how could they say trump is going to be
the healthiest president of every
president in history doesn't make sense
so
the starting point is the administration
lies about everything including trump's
health
therefore a healthy skepticism about
everything they tell us
is warranted now do i think trump
doesn't really have coronavirus no i
think trump does have corona oh we have
the white balance going on here
using an old uh an old paper towel maybe
the rest of uh
maybe used to clean up this guy's egg
and cheese remnants from this morning
but they've gotten the white balance
done
um so where was i i do think donald
trump has coronavirus but there is no
question
that the state of his condition may be
understated
let me give you one example um we were
told
yesterday that everything trump's doing
great mild mild mild
everything's going great at the same
time donald
trump received a an unapproved
polyclonal
antibody treatment as well as remdezavir
which has only been shown effective in
reducing mortality in the most serious
cases
it's not even we don't even have any
data about room desevere on
early mild cases so one would reasonably
be led to wonder
is this being are they throwing
everything at him because he's the
president
or is his condition more serious than we
are being told
because you know uh an antibody cocktail
that is in
in stage three clinical trials and not
approved
combined with rem deserve which is only
in theory useful
at least as far as we know on people who
might die
it raises real questions it raises real
questions now
again as i see people pointing out other
things why would trump risk a market
crash
by faking kovid if donald trump was
sure that by faking covet and then
miraculously recovering he would win the
election
trump doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
market in reality he cares about himself
okay so but i just think it's too risky
the idea that this would definitely be
good for trump
in the election it's just too risky it
takes him off the campaign trail for two
weeks i think it is just very
it's it's it's far too risky i believe
trump has coronavirus
he's canceling rallies you know he's
doing all this stuff so i i
i don't think that's the case i think
obviously
obviously he's going to try to use this
to his advantage uh and i even i i put
out a couple of tweets about this this
morning i hope you're all following me
on twitter if you're not you're missing
a lot
by the way now that we know kellyanne
conway tested positive even though
face shields are not as effective as
masks this lady right here must be
crossing her fingers that the face
shield protected her right and and
william barr
also real questions about whether he
might be positive
um ann applebaum had a great tweet do a
thought experiment if
biden were sick what would happen here's
my guess trump would be openly gloating
republicans would be loudly celebrating
their campaigns would try to put out ads
would put out ads trying to raise money
on the back of his illness absolutely
that would be going on uh but here is my
sense
so trump paid no taxes but gets a
helicopter ride to top-notch health care
all at taxpayer expense and in two weeks
we'll say a miracle cure which he wants
credit for testing
worked and you should vote for him does
that cover it and then i added
while trying to cancel obamacare
that's my take on it that this is going
to be
your opportunistically received plain
and simple
and that they are going to uh that
they're going to get out of it whatever
they can get out of it so we're standing
by for dr
sean conley momentarily will give us an
update on donald trump's condition can
we trust it or not well let's listen to
it first and see
i want to say thanks to michelle bose
michelle
is new member number one today at
jointpakman.com
thanks michelle for supporting the rare
weekend stream
the very rare weekend stream i have a
big uh saturday ahead of me
a lot of yard work going on i know jimmy
from philly insists i don't do my own
yard work but i do
uh today i've got a um i'm gonna be
raking leaves
because even though there's not much on
the ground yet i do want to get them out
of the way
so that i can do what probably will be
the last mow
of the season after mowing i will
pick up sticks and break them down into
their component parts putting them in a
lawn and leaf
refuse bag which i will bring to the
curb
and then i will do a large uh
large pick of tomatoes now i actually do
have to see
we are getting close to when i have to
pick all of my tomatoes
actually no we're it's still going to be
okay tonight 45 is borderline but then
i've got until wednesday because
thursday night it'll get down to 39
so actually uh wednesday thursday you
can look for a picture
of probably 20 pounds of green tomatoes
that i'll be pulling very very
powerfully
and then we'll be making some fried
green tomatoes i may pickle some of them
it's it's going to be the next two weeks
are going to be crazy
welcome if you're just joining us i do
see that somehow on this completely
random saturday morning stream we do
have
10 000 people joining us on youtube 3
300 on facebook and
1500 on twitch we are very very soon
going to get a press briefing from um
dr sean connelly on donald trump's
condition i'm being told rick scott is
now positive
rick scott coveted let's see
um
after he i'm not seeing where are you
seeing rick scott i'm not seeing rick
scott i did see that a number of
additional republican senators
have tested positive uh the partisan
divide
is um is stunning very very few
prominent democrats of course testing
positive they actually seem to be taking
this seriously it seems that social
distancing and masks work
uh quite quite certainly okay
uh i do see super chats coming in and
i'm gonna read some of them right now if
you have a message you want to get on
the screen feel free to send it i do
want to also say thanks to dollar
batteries who has subscribed with prime
as well as optical monk ac mommy
chickson
cider coil twitch bot
smoking guns and a lot of other people
whose usernames
i am visibly struggling to pronounce
david adams says have you heard of the
rumors that it was a body double in the
video going to marine one
um well but then trump got out of marine
one and it was pretty clear that it was
him wasn't it that doesn't that doesn't
really make a lot of sense to me
ant and sharon the bottom says hi david
do you think trump's doctors will tell
us the truth i doubt it
i i am reserving judgment until i see
what the presentation is
joe shalom says when trump speaks they
use an orange balance instead of white
balance right yeah today they use the
white balance because uh
it's um it's sean connelly who's going
to be speaking
um andrew moore says trump contracting a
pretty serious case of covid literally a
month prior to the election two days
after the first debate is the most 2020
thing ever
this is an insane year it's been an
insane year
uh san diego john says there's no way
all the doctors and all the other people
involved in his care could mislead us
into faking this he's got covid
i agree with you completely thanks to
mercury and tracy for grabbing youtube
subs stephen says do you grow
okra david or dry your own spices
i am not growing okra i don't know
um if it would be i don't know what
conditions
okra needs i don't know if the northeast
is a suitable
environment for okra but i do have my
own
uh it's not spices i'm growing my own
herbs i'm about to harvest them and dry
them i'm going to be harvesting
uh i've got two types of thyme lemon
thyme and
english time i believe or is it german
time english and
yeah i've got my parsley mint
is completely overgrown it's out of
control basil
and two types of oregano as well as sage
so we're getting very
very close to the harvest time for that
matthew says even with how he does
whatever he thinks
i think he is worse off than he says
can't imagine the public would know
otherwise
for national security reasons you know
one of the things that was reported
yesterday during the stream i did with
you guys
where we saw donald trump transported to
walter reed
despite having what at the time was
described as a mild case
i speculated that if there's fear that
trump is going to
get worse they would want to do the
transfer while trump doesn't have to be
carted out on a stretcher because that
would be very bad optically and indeed
uh the um washing i believe it was
washington post article yesterday
put out a statement saying that there
was a trump official that said they made
the decision to bring him
at this early stage to walter reed
specifically to avoid
um a situation where they have to get
him there where he can't even maybe
walk under his own power and that that
is exactly uh that was exactly what
was said now that doesn't mean he's
going to get worse in that degree but it
seems like they're thinking ahead
this is live if you're just joining us
welcome we are waiting for
a statement from dr sean conley the
white house doctor
we do know that donald trump has
received a very powerful
antibody treatment that is not yet
approved polyclonal
antibodies as from regeneron
as well as remdesseviere all raising
questions about exactly how serious
donald trump's case is
uh thanks to chris houlihan as well as
cornelia fenwinkel
t salesman and aj for a ow
all um supporting over on twitch
i will get to as many super chats as i
can before this starts
austin stickley is new member number two
on my website and as it says we are
counting patrons as well
glenn has just pledged on patreon and
moira o'brien has just pledged on
patreon
uh who are numbers three and four today
mueller's game says been watching you
since high school in 2015 sounds weird
but you really did change my perspective
and acted as a gateway to others like
kyle kulinski
love it coffee is for closers says will
mitch mcconnell be ramming through the
scotus vote via zoom even if he needs
the votes from senator hospital beds
so i at this point um
let me see what's the right way to i
don't want to say i'm sure let me i'll
say it in reverse
i am less confident than i've been in 10
days
that amy coney barrett gets uh gets
confirmed to the senate
to the supreme court rather by the
senate uh based on everything that's
going on
andrew moore is asking whether this is a
simulation i wish i knew
chad says david just explained his yard
work in detail what a guy
magpie's nest production says do you
think there is a possibility he may have
passed away
it's just some of stuff you said put
that in my head no i believe trump is
alive right now
uh who else do we have here
where did beetle greg beetle greg says
good morning from old england
good morning harutiyun dimirian
says hey david any plans to cover the
war going on in armenia
and are stock stop azeri aggression
uh you know i will cover it if i feel
like i have something to add
unlike some of these other grifters
hello
i don't feel a need to comment on
everything just for clicks
if i don't actually have something to
say about it that's just me
thanks to jenny henkel who has pledged
two dollars a month
on patreon and his supporter number five
today
i see some confusion so the number above
my head five that includes two things
that's
website memberships at joinpacman.com
and patreon pledges that's what shows up
there
sarah says david since trump's diagnosis
will overtake the media for who knows
how long
other than voting what do you recommend
we all do to help elect biden please say
it very strongly
vote so that it's just vote at this
point voting is now the election is now
early voting has started absentee voting
has started in a lot of different states
the time is now anybody you talk to
make sure they plan to vote and vote
yourself that is what we have to do we
can't allow this to
um uh uh stop the election
and say well you know there's that's
another theory that this is all to delay
the election this is not going to delay
the election
the election is happening the election
is happening
jared johnson says mr pakman i used to
be a big fan
but after yesterday's disinformation
fest slandering anything from peanut
butter to apples i honestly feel
betrayed
yeah yesterday i went on a completely
unhinged
screed about how smooth
unsalted peanut butter is the only real
peanut butter
uh for me and granny smith apples
are the only real apples for me and i it
actually
i l this was worse than when i critiqued
the women's march for being
anti-semitic at the top level the
commenting on apples and peanut butter
has actually destroyed my uh my entire
audience and business
jay says do you think trump's potential
addiction issues are playing a role here
they can't really let them go through
withdrawal during this can they
that's so speculative i don't i don't
even i can't say anything about that
ford says love your work man remember
once we got the ball back we need to
fight for progressive causes if we get
the ball back that is right if biden
gets in we've gotten the ball back we've
not scored then you've got to run the
score up okay
tony says trump could dump nuclear waste
on himself on live tv
we all know that fox and his cult would
still blame democrats in antifa yeah i
saw some wild stuff on fox news
yesterday which included
uh a discussion over whether biden out
of respect should stop his campaign
can you imagine biden gets ridiculed by
trump
for wearing a mask having people spaced
out at his campaign events
having uh uh small crowds rather than
big crowds
and out of respect to trump who's
disrespected the entire
uh population that has been affected by
coronavirus
by not wearing a mask and holding huge
rallies it's biden who needs to stop
campaigning to show respect to trump
give me a break
and then the other one i heard on fox
news was um
wait what was the other one so it was
biden should stop
oh um that trump's
recover there was something some
backwards thing about trump's recovery
will
prove something i don't i mean it was
delusional it's delusional what was
going on on fox news
um cm k ippen
says did he try taking an unproven
vaccine
and have it backfire when he hoped he
could sell it as i got super protected
from it selling point
right so there is something that can
happen with a vaccine that doesn't work
which is called an enhancement which
instead of
uh inoculating you can actually make it
so that
if you get the condition you get a worse
case of it
i don't believe if trump took the
vaccine and it hadn't
it was a bad vaccine and it was an
enhancement you know effect
um i don't think that it will give you
coronavirus my understanding is that if
you were to get it you might have a more
serious case
but you know that we any anything uh
could could happen and we're
merely uh speculating there was oh yeah
there were some chris wallace clips
chris wallace admitted that
trump was not actually tested before
the uh where was this oh i don't have
the clip
yeah chris wallace admitted that trump
got to the debate too late to be tested
so it was on the honor system which is
crazy
but here's the video i wanted to play
let's just keep an eye here
okay we still seem to be a few minutes
away check out this video of some trump
supporters yesterday out
supporting trump at the hospital my
thoughts right now is that
trump is in his 70s you know he is at
risk but he's taking it like a champ
you know compared to what a lot of other
people would say so
that's my take on the whole issue and
you know i have to ask the question why
aren't you wearing a mask
[Music]
well i'm young
and i'm not at risk for coving so
with the survival rates that we've seen
um
it's frankly listen by the way i i've
gotten messages that this kid is
obviously autistic and that this
we shouldn't even be playing this video
i don't know that i don't know that at
all hysteria what we're seeing with
colvin so
are you ever concerned it could be you
could possibly be asymptomatic and pass
it to someone else
yes i do have those concerns but
i don't buy into the fear-mongering
because where i'm at
you know i'm around other young people
you know we can power through this
but the fear-mongering about covet needs
to stop
i saw last night that he has positive
and
i saw he was laying i just felt drawn to
come you know to support art to support
our president does this situation make
you want to wear a mask now
you know i am of two minds with that
if i'm in real close proximity indoors
then i think yeah i do i i do
uh but when we have a lot of air moving
around
and whatnot i find it very
i just don't do it all right so there it
is uh some trump
supporters yesterday starting a vigil of
sorts
at uh walter reed medical center as you
can see it is still going on right now
these are live images we have uh
i mean you know it's just you know it's
so depressing what's going on
okay uh we are standing by for dr sean
conley
at walter reed medical center uh
expecting him any moment
any moment now i do want to say thanks
to oh people are people are doing stuff
howard hall
is new member number six today ralph
hartung has pledged via patreon and is
number seven
juarez aboytes is number eight
today raleigh
is number nine candice winfield is
number 10. ryan kelly is number 11.
teddy vinning is number 12 via patreon
fred stokes is number 13 via patreon
and natalie turner is number 14 today
via patreon
very much appreciate that uh thanks to
grandmaster benjamin feingold who has
cheered
a hundred bits very great to see ben i
very often join
ben's stream join i mean what i mean as
i watch i watch ben's chess streams in
the evenings
um and uh i see him
mostly defeat and sometimes get
distracted and lose
to very low rated chess players but we
highly recommend ben's chess stream
uh we had a raid from levy rosman the
other night which was great a lot of
very exciting things happening on twitch
uh let's see what else we've got going
on here
okay grace lord says i'm sick of the
false platitudes from the liberal media
as if trump and his cronies would do the
same
we cannot take the high road now he's on
the ropes if biden got sick they
wouldn't be praying absolutely
um i if listen if biden were sick they
would be saying
he has to drop out oh my twitch uh
subscriber thing
just glitched let's see if i can fix it
there it is i don't know what happened
there
apologies there we go
just tweaked it okay very good and
actually we've got a little too much
padding on the bottom there we go
uh yeah no if if biden were to get
coronavirus trump would immediately say
biden's not fit to be a candidate that
biden
should get out of the race etc etc
olay martin christensen says should
biden agree to put his campaign on hold
if trump mitch agreed to put scotus
nomination on hold listen the election
is in a month no matter what
the election is happening in a month no
matter what so i don't know why anybody
what why why biden would do that biden's
done everything right
it looks like this is mark meadows let's
listen to what's going on here
the
okay that is actually not mark meadows i
thought it was mark meadows but it was
hard to tell with the mask on
i believe if everybody heard the same
thing i heard
that they're just running a few minutes
behind which any one of us
uh any one of us could have guessed um
no question about it okay charlie says
david has your gardening ever reduced
you to actual tears either of sadness or
joy no that has not happened you know
when i got abu
the the closest i got to tears thanks to
my garden is one of my thin
spicy peppers was spicier than i thought
and it may have made my eyes water a
little bit but that's the closest
sceple says what happened to your stream
yesterday they cut midway
my entire computer turned rebooted
it's never happened before during a
stream i restarted the stream i think i
was offline in total for about five
minutes
but i restarted the stream we had a
major crash the entire system fell
rob yale with a beautiful 70 canadian
dollar super chat says great work david
thanks rob i really do appreciate that
support
a peter creighton's oh we just lost
peter hold on where'd that go
peter creighton says do you think the
republicans anti-china rhetoric will get
stronger because of this blame
china for infecting trump yeah a senator
kelly loffler already tweeted out
something along those lines
saying you know china is to blame for
flotus and potus
getting the virus they've already been
doing that for sure they will never take
any responsibility
uh dustin says hypothetical question if
both candidates are incapacitated from
kovid
and taken off the ballot before november
3rd what would happen i don't know
le i don't believe that that's going to
happen
killer of cereal says hey you're going
to keep an eye on how crypto fluctuates
i don't know if you remember me from
when stuff was happening in iraq
uh i don't i apologize anyway great work
and thanks for being a smart fair guy my
dude hope trump is okay
yeah i mean listen i i've held my uh
crypto
um for a long time uh i hold this you
know a small amount i want to say it's
about
uh wait a second what percent is that
um like 2 3
bitcoin price two three percent of my
net worth
um bitcoin is is back up above ten
thousand
uh i i did i've i've held uh bitcoin for
years but i did
increase my percep posses uh my uh
position
during that dip that happened at the
start of the pandemic so sort of like
mid-march when it dropped to about
55 hundred or six thousand i am not
making any
investment recommendations of any kind
i've just decided for myself
to um hold about three percent
of my assets in bitcoin and obviously
over the last uh six months it's done
really really well
okay subba says i imagine audible coughs
and orange hands pumping and clapping
from an open window during the doctor's
update
okay well we will see little scrubby
says love you david
dereten says david pakman is the
progressive gateway drug
trey wonders whether trump died from
drinking bleach come on guys
nathaniel says i always thought if a
sitting president contracted a lethal
virus they would not announce it due to
national security concerns what are your
thoughts
listen i don't know a lot of that stuff
is very
speculative what i know is they've
announced trump has coronavirus and i
believe that trump has coronavirus
that's uh that's what i can tell you
right now
i think a lot of this other stuff is
very very speculative
121 click bezel says i grow super hot
peppers california
carolina reapers moruga scorpions if
you're interested in some heat for your
winter chili let me know
no i don't really go any hotter than
to be honest i mean i i know that i'm
i've been trying to disabuse myself of
this title of beta male after jesse lee
peterson tagged me with it powerfully a
couple years ago
i don't really go any harder than a
jalapeno that's that's just me
and in fact i actually prefer i prefer
what's the red there's a red one that's
more of a dull
heat it's more of a dull heat is it an
anaheim
or a serrano there's a red spicy pepper
that i actually prefer the taste of
significantly
fresno that's it fresno pepper i love
those fresno peppers that's a that's a
beautiful pepper
um okay what else do we have here
hallie schultz says i'm reminded of dr
frank's book we're forced to be the
begrudgingly worried parents
despite his excessively reckless
behavior in a sense that is true
that is very true dan green
says sources say trump may decide to
refuse the results of his covet test
doctor
stand back and stand by okay
uh very clever christina says david
please tell mario i wish we were
listening together i miss and love you
christina mario would like to be
listening to this stream together
she misses you and she loves you a
hallmark moment
tyler says the greatest takeaway from
the debate is that biden's dementia is a
fabricated lie pushed by the right
to invalidate biden's candidacy yeah we
didn't need the debate to tell us that
tyler
but you're absolutely spot on mr vister
has subscribed with twitch prime and
says thanks for everything david
i love your perspectives and personality
thank you i'm glad you're here
also surly badger has subscribed with
prime
rascallo love has subscribed with prime
and razzer also appreciate razzer
let me just get caught up on thank yous
here uh nicole pin
is new member number 15 today nancy
is a patron and supporter number 16.
nicole fagan is number 17. peggy
harkness is number 18
and elizabeth davey is number 19
via patreon also tamara skye
or tamara or tamara it's probably tamara
is a supporter number 20 today
if you're just joining us we were
scheduled to hear from dr
sean connelly at the top of the hour
that's
nine minutes ago some gentleman who was
having
serious issues keeping his mask in place
came out about
five minutes ago and said that the
doctors were just running
a little bit behind but that we should
expect to hear from them very very soon
this is the washington post feed we also
have a video thanks to usa today
there are trumpists including even
children as you can see here
holding some kind of vigil outside
walter reed medical center
for donald trump there are trump flags
there is police tape
and there are american flags uh we
also let's see what abc is reporting
here the president is
as cecilia mentioned uh hospitalized
just over 31 days before
this is dan harris i just had dan harris
on the program a couple months ago
debates up in the air it is an
unprecedented twist
in a u.s presidential election abc's
rachel scott
is also right there in washington this
morning with much more on what
what's ahead for this unpredictable
campaign rachel good morning to you
dan this is truly an unprecedented turn
not only does the president have the
virus but now those
two positive infections with the people
charged with leading his re-election
efforts the chairwoman of the rnc and
the president's campaign manager have
tested positive two
there it is all right so uh that gives
us sort of a sense of the degree of
uh of of of of uh what do we call it
uh i don't wanna call it panic i don't
wanna call it glee
just you know this is a media story that
now
my guesses is going to have so many more
people paying attention
generally speaking to the news um
uh through through and beyond uh through
and beyond the election it's not even
really concern yeah i don't know i don't
even know what to call it it's
interesting
um okay other super chats continue to
come in
skc says will trump based upon the
sympathy vote
okay i'm guessing there's a word there
maybe you mean a word missing will trump
win based upon the sympathy vote if
pence assumes the office before election
day
what happens with the trump pence ballot
when a vice president
um is temporarily made the person in
charge
the trump is still it's still the trump
presidency so i don't believe there
would be an issue with trump being on
the ballot but certainly it's going to
raise all sorts of questions about the
path forward
gail says thanks from arkansas yes there
are sane people here there are sane
people in every state gail
semyes law sem j slaw
says love the stream isn't it ironic
that trump just made fun of biden's big
mask yeah it's
it's a sick irony really cameron epple
says texas viewer here what are your
thoughts about greg abbott limiting
absentee mail-in ballot boxes to one per
county in texas
no surprise we know from polling that uh
it is biden supporters who are more
likely to want to vote by mail
than trump voters so you make it tougher
and you help trump it's very simple but
the fact that they're even worried in
texas is quite telling
that's that's really an interesting sign
um carla blake says why didn't you
invite kyle from secular talk into your
race to a million
carla that doesn't make any invite him
uh
i don't know listen i didn't i didn't
create any race to a million
um sam cedar created a race to a million
and i happened to win it but let's see i
don't even know how many subscribers
kyle has is he close to a million let's
see
um oh he's at only he's at 885 right now
so he's i mean you know we're i think
now where are we now we're at a million
30 now so
i mean it's i i just i didn't even
realize that there there was
there was anybody else uh close at the
time where we were pushing for the
million
but sure i mean you know i'm glad to
have kyle involved in anything
wendy says david my husband and i really
enjoy your show you are genuine and
straightforward thank you for your work
i appreciate that
javi rodriguez says if trump has to drop
out or resign would pence be more
difficult for biden to beat
you know my my gut is that if trump
drops out and is replaced with pence
that it's not it's not going to be about
pence versus biden it's going to be
about the chaos of we lost our guy
and i think it would be really bad for
the republican party i
i just don't think i don't think if
pence takes over it's about
who do you prefer between pence and
biden i think it's people will abandon
trump and it'll sort of be a
um it'll be a bail it'll be an escape
hatch in fact
for many reluctant trump voters that's
my
instinct thanks to val athanasiu
who has supported via patreon and his
supporter number 21 today
rakan al-ahmad has supported via patreon
at the
50 level and is supporter number 22
today
and ron lemons has made a pledge on
patreon
and is supporter number 23. very much
appreciate that remember that
both website memberships and patreon
count for this bar
that we're only now two away from
filling up
but we always keep the biggest share of
your contributions
when you sign up at joinpakman.com why
because we control the entire system the
whole system is
ours nobody's taking these slices
as andrew yang would say of different
payments um and the coupon code 2020 now
above my head will save you 66 percent
so
this is going to be my one and only
invitation to you
i'm imploring you to grab a membership
at joinpakman.com it's a beautiful day
to do it
uh sunny day and hopefully we will get
all good health news about all humans on
this planet today
that is the way that i am approaching
this we want
everybody to be healthy and we will soon
be hearing from dr
sean conley uh white house doctor with
an
update on donald trump's condition
that's happening
very very soon um okay let's see
christopher long says david long time
fan however i was slightly upset after
hearing your comments on the tutsi
people and the rwandan genocide i've not
commented on that
so christopher i think you might be
trying to draw me into a non-existent
controversy
uh however if the rwandan genocide be
because this is an interesting topic
if you're interested in learning about
the rwandan genocide
um there's a book by philip gurvich
which i highly recommend called um
it's something like uh we are here to
notify you that tomorrow our families
will be killed or something like that
it's an aggressive title philip gorovich
rwandan genocide let me look at what the
name of that book is
this is a real non-fiction classic we
wish to inform you
that tomorrow we will be killed with our
families by philip gorovich it's
a um
it's a 22 year old book at this point
but i highly recommend it and uh i have
not
said anything about the rwandan genocide
publicly
alan says please acknowledge that
couscous is not pasta it is the kernel
of the usually wheat grain what i'm
finding is that couscous is pasta
okay let me take a look here
um yeah
check check this out you guys i think
are this might be
at the risk of dividing my audience um
couscous is a tiny pasta
made of wheat or barley now i do agree
if it's barley it's not really pasta
right but if it's wheat coarsely ground
durum wheat semolina that's pasta
that's oh am i not allowed to talk about
holy [ __ ] is couscous illegal
people are telling me you can't talk
about couscous on twitch
sorry uh i believe it is pasta i believe
it is pasta
barley couscous i've never had i prefer
that larger grain israeli couscous
that's a good one
and by grain by grain i mean pasta thank
you
reed says not only did wallace say trump
didn't get tested before the debate
he also said trump's family were either
not wearing masks at all or took them
off that is true
that is true flying scotsman says do you
think trump deserves this
you know i don't really think in those
terms there is no question that
if you were to believe in karma which i
don't you would think
that if you lead one of the worst
responses to the virus in the world
and ridicule by joe biden for taking it
seriously
on and on and on and on you would think
if you believed in a sort of karmic
universe
that trump deserves it uh at the same
time
i don't really think in those terms uh
so i'm going to
sort of stop short there i see people
asking if gnocchi is pasta
of course now what is controversial
about that
is that if you have ricotta gnocchi
that's a cheese that's a cheese
but i believe that typically there would
be some uh there would be some i think
there's usually some
uh wheat there you can also have potato
gnocchi
no there's potato gnocchi and there's
ricotta gnocchi guys
i know about about potato gnocchi
now i have to explain pasta to people
can you imagine
um
okay potato gnocchi have a tendency to
become gummy or leaden when weighed down
with flour
or overhandled ricotta gnocchi are more
foolproof
ricotta gnocchi guys ricotta gnocchi
please
i prefer it to potato gnocchi
potato gnocchi's not that good i i'm
sorry guys it's just not
okay chris says hen his kids arrive at
the hospital we will know it's close to
the end
okay that would that would be serious
mitesh desai
says they don't get that a healthy
person of lower risk probably gave this
to trump
very true very true
um okay
bob leblanc says breaking news president
trump moved to icu
on ventilator anonymous sources close to
the president say
i don't buy that uh trump
moved to icu i don't think so
yeah i'm finding nothing about that i
think that that's uh
i think that that's trolling
let's see guys no no no people are
saying it's rare that an argentinian
doesn't like gnocchi i like gnocchi
ricotta gnocchi in argentina it's
ricotta gnocchi
that are the big thing okay trump
i see you latest let's see
yeah i'm not seeing anything about trump
being in the icu
so that uh if anybody has a real source
on that let me know
michael blanco says oh
hold on a second i lost it where was
that
wait a second okay here it is michael
blanco says stupid for biden to pull
anti-trump ads just because he got cove
it doesn't change anything in respect to
how destructive trump has been as
president
correct uh bing says i'm wondering if he
had this for a while but has been lying
about it possible
hardcore fps says what did you do before
youtube
well that's an interesting i don't
really know how to answer that i mean
i i had the show uh
while i was in grad school and youtube
became one component of it i mean i
guess nothing
i guess i was just a kid before youtube
i've never really had a real job
that's a half joke by the way that's a
half joke okay
kyle says no symptoms before debate
unconfirmed testing before debate
missed testing at debate announces
positive shortly after debate
change hmm okay
seth says story just broke with cal
cunningham getting caught texting very
tame messages to someone who wasn't his
wife i'm worried
i saw that yeah i'm not even going to
talk about that it's just it's lame
lee says david trump's doctors asked for
and received his medicine by using the
compassionate use request which is rare
i think he is very ill
if that's true that that would be
relevant
david belski says with it being so easy
to get tested in new jersey with results
in two to three days
it should be a responsibility to get one
once a week yeah um i mean
we definitely need to be doing more
surveillance testing of populations that
are not
symptomatic i was tested on wednesday i
mentioned this yesterday
i was um i i had what i think are sort
of like some kind of
late summer allergies and my doctor
very very confidently said let's just
rule out coronavirus because if it were
that we wouldn't want to miss it
and so i was sent for a coronavirus test
he so let me do the math here
he put the order in so this is
massachusetts my doctor put the order in
on tuesday
on wednesday i got the call from the
scheduling center
saying you know come in uh to a
drive-through
thursday i went now here's what's
interesting when i got there
the schwab for lack of a better term
that they used it was way thinner
than the ones we were seeing on tv early
that they were ramming all the way back
into people's brains
so that when i saw that thin schwab i
was like this is good okay
and then she said this is just going to
take five seconds the nurse did i was in
my car i just went like this
she put it in to the nose the left
nostril and i thought
this is fine this is fantastic but she
was only aligning it
then it went in two more inches and at
that point
i i visibly recoiled and she gave me a
five count as she twisted it one two
three four
five took it out said have a good one
off you go
and then within minutes of learning
yesterday morning that donald trump had
tested positive when i woke up uh i also
had an
email from the uh you know patient
portal system saying my nasopharyngeal
swab
had come back negative for uh
for sars co v2 which was good
which was good um oh some people not
liking that story people in the twitch
chat saying that that the story of my
schwa being schwabbed uh
made them anxious or maybe did they mean
the gnocchi story made them anxious i
don't know
okay so that is that let me say a few
twitch thank yous
amends or solar mushroom
wurmazer surly badger fimi
have all um supported on twitch
which i appreciate
dean oldfield says keep up the good work
david this is via super chat you're an
asset to democracy
rob asks whether tucker carlson compared
trump to a sexual assault victim if
that's true i didn't see it and it
sounds crazy
by the way did you guys see tucker
carlson's being sued for slander
if i recall correctly we did the story
on the bonus show last week
and what fox news lawyers are arguing in
court is that when tucker carlson says
things that sound like
facts the context of the entire show
should tell you that they're not really
facts that he engages in hyperbole and
non-literal commentary
this is the alex jones defense when alex
jones was sued i think it was
for libel lawyer said alex jones is
essentially playing a character
and he's playing the character of a news
guy but it's really not it's really he's
almost like an actor
and so that's the argument that fox news
is making to defend tucker carlson which
is like just because tucker says
something and it's like presented as
news presented as facts
any reasonable person would know that
it's not and of course like this is the
game fox news plays
where their audience has such low media
literacy
that they can't even distinguish between
news and opinion programming
never mind the fact that someone on fox
might say something that's not true
it's crazy it's crazy what's going on
if you're just joining us we are running
very late on what was supposed to be an
urgent
11am eastern briefing from donald
trump's doctor
uh sean conley someone wandered out of
the building
at about five past and said we were just
a few minutes away
we don't know how much longer it's going
to be but we've got a nice crowd here
waiting we've got about 21 000 people
watching with me on youtube
about 4 000 on facebook and 3 000 on
twitch that's what seven and 21
about 28 000 of us together and i'm glad
we're all here together
waiting for the latest update on donald
trump's
medical condition i do want to say
thanks to some folks that are signing up
on my website i don't want to fall
behind and i'm not ignoring you
um let's just just because i can tell
where things are going
let's go for 50 and see where we get i
want to say thanks to
rick roselli who's number 24
billy taylor's number 25 denise miller
not dennis miller denise miller is
number 26
alan daley 27 janine bordeaux
28. zach jacobson is number 29
jennifer emery is number 30. craig
newcomb is number 20 31 and conrad
blot is number 32
there's a couple others there and i will
uh certainly thank everybody
puffin says pro tip wear a mask when
grinding hot peppers
you know for me the thing with the
peppers is i wear contacts
and if i touch the peppers and then i
forget and i don't fully wash my hands
when i take the contacts out
it's not fun it is not fun i should
really wear rubber gloves is what i'm
realizing
steven brewster says trump might get his
wish granted to be president for the
rest of his life
that's that's uh that's dark that's dark
syed ahmad says trumpers and
anti-massacres should take this
seriously clearly the virus doesn't care
if you're one of the most protected men
on the planet yeah
trump in theory could have the most
protective bubble around him and he
still got it now in reality
trump ignored and the the guidelines
and put himself in dangerous situations
so so the reality is
that although trump could be the most
protected person on the planet he wasn't
in practice
uh sam says trump is not in great shape
will he realize
this is worse than the flu maybe push
his followers to start taking this
seriously
or maybe just beat it and talk about how
strong and amazing he is yeah it could
be it could be both
um so i see tom sent a super chat saying
that trump's
suite at walter reed has an icu i'm not
denying that trump could be
placed into an icu i'm just not seeing
anything uh suggesting that right now
let's just refresh my my twitter feed
and see
what we see in person campaign rallies
still on for the trump campaign but
without trump
it will be pence instead okay
let's see pence plans to hold an
in-person rally on thursday
joe biden is telling people to wear
masks quite a contrast guys
look at this pence will hold an
in-person rally on thursday as trump is
hospitalized for kovid
joe biden wearing a mask will protect
you as well as those around you
contrast uh if we're gonna look at this
i'll just turn up the audio here so that
we don't miss it if it starts
what else do we have
dave weigel
with some tweets paul graham okay
might be good time to elect people who
will stop the virus instead of people
who spread it well said
sam vinograd who i like says in a moment
like this i really wish we could trust
anything this administration tells us
credible communication publicly and also
privately to foreign counterparts
is critical during crises our inability
to trust what they tell us
creates added uncertainty and
instability indeed
um here are the trump's not wearing
masks at the debate
on thursday as you can see
george takei we love george takei
yeah a lot of people getting the virus
medy hassan getting a new show on
peacock which is exciting i sent him a
congrats
uh what else do we have bandy lee
who wants trump to uh end his campaign
says that we have an opportunity here to
get trump out now that's pretty
aggressive
okay so nothing about icu and trump i
think certainly
if trump were in the icu or if there
were credible rumors of it we would be
seeing them there that's my instinct
that's my instinct but i could certainly
be wrong about that
other super chats coming in charlie
moreno says maybe trump recorded several
videos of himself to be released over
time a cue from kim jong-un's death
faking playbook
to avoid prosecution perhaps listen it's
like
anything is theoretically possible but i
don't see the point in engaging in such
uh it's indefeasible speculation it's
like who could possibly say
no that didn't happen but we have no
evidence that that's what's going on
andre says slightly off topic but flu
shots are still important if you're not
immunocompromised i had my first one
today yeah i got my flu shot actually in
late uh
late august my arm hurt for about 36
hours
and then i was fine chris back says
david are you religious atheist or
agnostic watching from australia i
am culturally jewish i am ethnically
jewish and i am religiously agnostic
prior guy says working on a song pac-man
fever
based on the buckner and garcia song
from the 80s stand by i would love that
pickles and cheese says how will the
right use this to blame the left
oh just watch fox news and you'll see
tokyo juan with a very sad message my
beloved father
passed away from covet and i'm still
devastated i can't muster
any sympathy for someone who purposely
downplayed the pandemic but i don't wish
him death
i want him to face accountability
um i i am so sorry to hear that
and i i cannot imagine uh
what you've experienced and i tend to
have your
same feeling which is i don't want
trump to be removed because he dies i
want trump to be repudiated by the
voters brutally
brutally brutally repudiated by the
voters i agree with you
uh cmk says reminds me of vigils the
romans had for caligula who
offered their lives to the gods for his
didn't go well for
them when he made them go through with
it
yeah to meed huda says have they
identified patient zero in the white
house could it be the president himself
i don't believe that they have
it is increasingly looking like it was
the amy coney barrett
nomination that could have been the
super spreader event
thanks to hannibal lecter and wumbas as
well as
mochi yazzie for subscribing with prime
now there is a dessert mochi ice cream
uh that that is a dessert i love
if i had to rank i should do a dessert
ranking
is there actually a tear maker for
desserts
that would be interesting to do
dessert tier list yeah i could actually
do a dessert
listen i don't even really need to do it
right now
here are the top desserts okay everybody
get ready for this
this is in no particular order flan
i'm argentinian guys okay so flan thanks
to david chadman by the way for gifting
10 subscriptions on twitch the real chad
move
flan is a top dessert pistachio baklava
is a top dessert tiramisu
when well made is a top dessert mochi
ice cream
is a top dessert and now this is
controversial
in the uh uh in in the jewish world
whether what i'm about to name is or is
not a dessert some people consider this
an afternoon snack
but chocolate bobcat chocolate bobcat
for me
is uh it's hard to beat a good chocolate
babka
and those would probably be my top five
desserts
um yeah i don't i feel really good about
that
i know it's very it's a very culturally
influenced list of desserts for sure you
can you can definitely see that
but uh it is what it is baba ganoush is
not a dessert
i hate to break it to you guys but that
is not and
pie i i don't even like pie pie is just
off for me
i couldn't i just don't care about pie
don't care about it
don't care about it and from the
standpoint of cakes
i like a good moist like a black forest
chocolate cake um
yeah so that's that i don't know what
else to tell you guys
yeah tart tatan is very good but it's
that would probably be in my top 10 but
not in my top five four or five
okay um let's see sharon
asks whether anyone really thinks the
doctor will tell the truth what what do
you guys think in chat
are we going to get anything real from
sean connelly here do we think we're
going to hear the truth
from sean connelly about trump's
condition what do we think
most people are thinking not the full
truth yeah
i tend to agree
yep okay so it seems like it's mostly
mostly nose
i don't know where on earth this doctor
is let's see if there's any news here
from abc
about uh what's going on we fast-paced
schedule including
of course that debate in cleveland the
rally in minnesota
but at least a couple of his advisers uh
say that they
were worried when they saw the way he
was on wednesday night
that he might have been exposed to
coronavirus so who knows i i don't
wednesday night you can make the
assumption that we didn't learn about
the positive test for more than 24 hours
after that agree with john
yeah yeah i agree with john completely
you know
this is where we've we heard at the
beginning of this pandemic
the keys to controlling a viral outbreak
or an infectious disease outbreak are
test trace and isolate and that
contact tracing as jonathan i'm sure can
speak to
has been kind of bumpy so far on the
part of the white house you know they
need to do some detective
yeah they certainly do uh we just had a
400 australian dollar super chat come in
i don't know what that is in u.s dollars
but it seems like it's a lot
from matt newham or newam matt who says
alaska has a ballot proposal to
introduce rank choice voting as does
massachusetts
could this be a motivation to turn out
the vote
does alaska small number of electoral
votes and far west location mean it gets
ignored
and does its small population mean a
small increase in turnout could make it
competitive asking from australia
okay yeah a lot of questions here so um
i yes i hope that people so
uh ranked choice voting is the lack of
rank choice voting
oh it looks like something is happening
here hold on
the lack of ranked choice voting is
something that keeps people from voting
so putting that on the ballot
is an excellent idea and yes because of
alaska's small population it absolutely
is reasonable that a relatively small
increase in turnout could shift the
results
let's see what we've got here uh
looks like this finally maybe about to
start
that guy that just walked out is the guy
who previously came out okay this must
be a doctor we have a
number of gentlemen uh and and
do we have any ladies as well i can't
tell uh we are about to be brief now
about donald trump's condition everybody
wearing masks and lab coats
let's see what uh what we hear
pretty good morning everyone
thank you for coming uh dr sean connolly
physician of the president uh this
morning i'd like to start by
first sharing that the president and
first family first lady
extremely grateful for the enormous
outpouring of support and prayers
that the whole world and country have
been providing and sharing
i'd like to thank colonel andrew barr
and all the medical and support staff
here at walter reed
for their tireless efforts providing
everything and anything the medical team
the president and i could need this
morning the president
is doing very well behind me are some of
the members
of uh the president's medical team whom
i'd like to introduce
dr sean dooley pulmonary critical care
dr brian garibaldi pulmonary critical
care
dr robert browning pulmonary critical
care
dr jason blaylock infectious disease
dr wes campbell infectious disease
dr john hodgson anesthesia
major kurt klein army nurse commander
megan nasworthy
navy nurse lieutenant juliana lavopa
navy nurse lieutenant lieutenant
commander john shea
clinical pharmacist and not present with
us our lieutenant beth carter
lieutenant maureen meehan both navy
nurses and dr jesse show now
director of our executive medicine
program
as reported yesterday consultation with
this group
i recommended we bring the president up
to walter reed
as a precautionary measure to provide
state of the art monitoring and any care
that he may need
just 72 hours into the diagnosis now the
first week of covid and a particular day
7-10 are the most critical
in determining the likely course of this
illness
at this time the team and i are
extremely happy with the progress the
president has made
thursday he had a mild cough and some
nasal congestion and fatigue
all of which are now resolving and
improving at this time i'd like to bring
up dr dooley to discuss some of the
specifics
of the president's care
okay thank you and good afternoon i'm dr
sean dooley as dr conley mentioned
i'll start off by mentioning what an
incredible
uh how incredibly proud i am of our
medical team assembled behind me
uh and the honor it's been to care for
the the president over these last
uh 24 hours here at walter reed
he's receiving outstanding
multi-disciplinary
care the state of the science for
coronavirus infection
we are monitoring him very closely uh
for any evidence of complications from
either the coronavirus illness or the
therapies that we are prescribing to
make him better we have monitored his
cardiac function
his kidney function his liver function
all of those
are normal and the president this
morning is not on
oxygen uh not having difficulty
breathing
or walking around uh the white house
medical unit upstairs
he's in exceptionally good spirits and
in fact as we were completing our
multi-disciplinary rounds this morning
uh the quote he left us with was i feel
like i could walk out of here today and
that was a very encouraging
comment from the president moving
forward i'll go ahead and introduce dr
garabaldi who will talk about some of
our therapeutics
and the plan for plan of care for today
thank you
thank you dr dooley and i'd like to echo
the sentiment from the entire team what
a
honor and a privilege it is to be part
of this multi-disciplinary unit to care
for the president
um about 48 hours ago the president
received
a special antibody therapy directed
against the coronavirus and we're
working very closely with the company to
monitor him
in terms of that outcome um yesterday
evening he received his first dose of
ivory rem deserver
and our plan is to continue a five-day
treatment course for room destiny
that doesn't make sense and the big plan
for today since he's in such great
spirits and doing well is to encourage
him to eat
to drink to stay hydrated to be up out
of bed
and to be working and doing the thing
things that he needs to do
uh to get well i'll refer dr conway to
any any questions
thanks brian it's important to note the
president's been fever-free for over 24
hours uh we remain cautiously optimistic
um but he's doing great um
with that oh one other note it should be
clear that uh he's got plenty of work
to get done from the chief of staff
and he's doing it um with that if
there's a couple questions about the
president's health
uh in the last couple days sir can you
tell us the president's
oxygen saturation levels yeah so the the
last uh
saturation that we had up walking around
he was about 96 percent
and he's receiving notes he has not
received any supplemental oxygen he's
not on oxygen right now that's right
that's not the
question that wasn't the question you
guys noticed that right at all
he's he's not needed anybody any uh this
morning today at all
today no he's you guys got what's going
on right
when he might be discharged oh well
i don't want to put a hard date on that
um he's doing so well
but the with a known course of the
illness
day seven to ten we get really concerned
about the inflammatory phase phase two
um given that we provided some of these
uh
advanced therapy so early in the course
a little bit earlier than most of the
patients we know and follow
it's hard to tell where he is on that
course and so
every day we're evaluating does he need
to be here what does he need
and where is he going what do you see is
the probability that he will need
supplemental oxygen going forward
i don't want to put a percentage on that
but but right now all indicators
are that uh that he'll remain off of
oxygen
going forward in terms of like blood
clots pneumonia bacterial infection what
do you see
is the risk on that front well we know
that all of them
are risks associated with this condition
he is receiving all of the standard of
care
and beyond per routine you know
international coveted protocols um so
we're monitoring for all that
um but at the moment there's no cause
for concern you said he was he's
fever-free now what was his fever when
he had one sir
uh i'd rather not give any specific
numbers but he but he did have a fever
uh thursday into friday and since friday
morning
he's had none okay and what was the date
on top of the other
antibodies i'm sorry on top of the
antibodies
so rem deserver works a little bit
differently than the antibodies
we're maximizing all aspects
of his care attacking this virus
you know multi-pronged approach as the
president
um i didn't want to hold anything back
if there was any possibility that it
would add value to his care and
expedite his return um i wanted to take
it
and the team agreed and that's what this
is weird doctor what was the date of the
president's last negative test
i'm not going to get into all the
testing going back
but he and all the staff routine uh
routinely uh are tested
um and so these liars what is the ppe
protocol
for uh president trump receiving
visitors and doctors
it's the same as any hospital has
we have an area that's uh that clean
that you put your equipment on
and then beyond that everybody is fully
gowned up
masks gloves um we're protecting
ourselves and him
has have you done a screen has there's
been any sign of any lung damage
whatsoever
we are we are following all of that we
do daily ultrasounds we do daily lab
work
the team is tracking all of that has
there been any sign of damage i'm not
going to go into specifics of what the
findings of that people
has he ever been on supplemental oxygen
he
right now he is not honest i know you
keep saying right now but should we read
into the fact that he
yesterday and today he was not on oxygen
so he has not been on it during this his
covent treatment
he's not on oxygen right now considered
as a vibrant treatment option for the
president uh we discussed it he asked
about it
uh he's not on it now and doctor what uh
symptoms has he also experienced
difficulty breathing
no no he has not never did a little
cough
he had the fever more than anything he's
felt run down why would he have been
who is handling contact tracing is that
the white house or cdc
the the white house uh uh white house
medical unit in conjunction with uh
you know collaboration with cdc and
local state and health departments are
conducting all contact tracing for cdc
guidelines
when was the positive diagnosis made uh
you said 72 hours that would prevent
wednesday
yeah uh so thursday afternoon uh
following uh uh following the news of a
closed contact
is when we repeated testing um and
giving kind of clinical indications and
a little bit more concern
and that's when that late that night uh
we got the pcr confirmation that uh that
he was
is there any of the virus during the
debate became infected
not going to go into that um as far as
his care
it's irrelevant there you go or when he
became infected
yeah we're not going to go into that uh
we're just tracking his clinical careers
and providing the best care we can
well president trump has to say walter
reed to get uh the five day range of
your treatment um we've discussed that
right now uh
if he needs all five days uh that will
likely be the course
um but again every day we're reviewing
with the team
uh his needs for being here and uh and
as soon as he gets to the point where
it's not a requirement
he may still need some care but if we
can provide that downtown
at the house then we will transition at
that point as long as it's
safe and appropriate the team agrees in
addition to his weight
does he have any other risk factors that
make him more at risk for sort of a
severe case
well not particularly i mean he's he's
74
he's male and he is slightly overweight
slightly other than that he's very
healthy
uh his cholesterol is great his blood
pressure is great he's not
on medication for that um he's up and
active
you saw the uh his activity the days
leading up to
the long hours and everything else he's
able to handle it
can you provide other vitals like heart
rate blood pressure and temperature
um so his his heart rate is in the
70s the 80s his blood pressure has
remained
where it's where it's historically been
drawing our physicals which is
uh you know 110 to 120 stock he's great
it's never budged i've had no concerns
there so why was the decision made to
transfer him here
because he's the president of the united
states and obviously if doctors have
found that the prone position is helpful
for kovit has he been in that at all
no we actually he asked about that he
did thursday into friday
um he's been briefed by the task force
and all the scientists for months
and he brought that up you know as we
were discussing his cough smart
time his oxygen levels were okay we
didn't feel like we needed to do it
we came up here we discussed it with the
team as well um we
consider all options but he has not
needed any of that why wasn't the first
lady admitted as well
uh the first lady's doing great thanks
for asking uh she has no indication
for hospitalization advanced therapy
she's convalescing at home
uh thank you i'm gonna try to pin you
down one more time i know you said there
was no obvious yeah
yeah he's not on oxygen but did he have
today and he didn't receive anything on
thursday and he's
what's today saturday uh no no thursday
no thursday no friday or saturday that's
fine that was why we were thursday no
oxygen
none at this moment yeah
so has the president actually been
admitted as a patient
to this hospital the president is a
patient
at walter reed national military medical
center is he on any steroids
he's impressed thank you yes thank you
very much thank you thank you
okay thank you what the hell was that
what so
i mean i guess the takeaways are
at some point trump was on oxygen right
i mean if trump at no point was on
oxygen
they would say trump at no point was on
oxygen do we agree i'm trying to
i'm trying to sort this through piece by
piece at some point trump was on
oxygen can we reasonably deduce that
okay everybody agrees with that and then
also trump had coronavirus
far earlier than has been said can can
we agree with that as well because
they're talking about an
antibody treatment already 48 hours ago
and they're refusing to say when he
tested positive so i think that's the
other thing
that we can no guys hipaa it's not
hipaa the the fact that they're even
having this press conference hit us out
the window
trump has okayed this briefing so it's
not about hipaa that they're not giving
those details
um
yeah so it seems like those are the uh
those are those are the takeaways very
very odd
very very odd stuff um
he probably had oxygen at the white
house okay yeah i mean that's what
that's what seems logical okay so that's
the briefing from dr
sean conley i see over on twitch a lot
of people saying that we need to add
emotes please email me through the
website contact form and tell me which
bttv emotes you want me to add and i
will do it
it's just impossible to keep up with it
in the twitch chat just contact me and
tell me exactly
which emotes you want me to enable and
i'm glad to do it
um okay so that is that
i would not be shocked if we get another
one of these tomorrow
uh and if that's the case i will set up
a live stream and we'll be here
with you guys but in the meantime thanks
for joining me
i don't know how much we learned from
this but i am glad
i was able to spend the time the time
with you and we will see if we get any
more information throughout the day
or tomorrow see you soon
you